bella a tutti i ragazzi è vero che solo
video sono fa vj oggi porto un video su
nelle saghe videoludiche che ho
preferito nella mia vita che final
fantasy esiste il final fantasy versione
borg che sarebbe final fantasy xiv
shadow brig
ho creato lungo personaggio per potervi
introdurre a questo mondo fantastico di
final fantasy appunto il personaggio in
questione si chiama brambilla fumagalli
il signor mila ragazzi non arriva a
vedere la pianta talmente l'altezza è un
problema però o non c'è tra tutti i
personaggi che si potranno creare io
veramente cento il più basso perché in
generale secondo me nessuno se l'è mai
scelto non è solo scelto solo io quindi
non discriminiamo i character antico
vita che usiamo anche quelli ma come si
suol dire ragazzi nella botte piccola
c'è il mana buono e oggi vi facciamo
vedere quanto vale il mio umano vedo
subito che anni ma se connesso al server
anno non è saggia sono già a livello 2
ragazzi perché o ex fatto un pochettino
prima di registrare però volevo dirvi
che di base del final fantasy 14 puoi
giocare fino al 35 completamente free
quindi se volete giocare con me non
costa niente fino a livello 35 potete
già scaricarlo trovate il link in
descrizione scaricatelo tutti perché
sennò vi faccio sbirciare sotto le gonne
delle persone scherzavo dicevo semi
aggiungete poi agli amici facciamo
meglio group e facciamo un altro video
insieme teoricamente quindi se ci siete
tutti quanti scaricatevi il gioco e il
mandato il messaggio qua in game
queste sono le mount che sono i chocobo
già in testa di bovino non sa che
halloween è finito da un pezzo
allora sto usando questo oggetto che ho
ricevuto che è un oggetto fantastico
incredibile io so che cos'è sono
ritornato al menu se andiamo su starz
gli ho preparato tutto guarda qua
guarda la legge leggete quasi scritto pd
velo se sei libero 70 ragazzi perché io
sono persona pigra mi sono comprato il
busto a livello 70 potete farlo anche
voi siamo tornati ragazzi nella nostra
bellissima città da un minuto all'altro
possa sorpassare di 70 livelli così
perché mi andava provato anche un po le
skill per essere un po più sfilato
skills va bene vuoi vedere quanto ci
mette a far fuori il livello 1 adesso
giusto per curiosità solo per vedere va
bene allora ghazi non ancora testato se
effettivamente cadere dalla cascata mi
fa danno o meno se cado nell'acqua
questa cosa farà ripeto è meglio per
scoprirlo in live che che non quindi va
bene allora andiamo giù dove ci sono i
spriggan se riesco ad andare giù dritto
3 2 1 mi sono fatto malissimo però non
sono morto level sync cosa ragazzi
l'avessi casa praticamente quando tu sei
un livello troppo alto per poter fare
tipo delle queste robe del genere ti
sincronizza a livello per poter prendere
il ritmo aia porca vacca tina mercato
amici
vabbè però eva mi scusi non ho visto per
poter camarca non so parlare quando sono
sotto elezioni adesso parlare per poter
prendere aerei world giuste completarla
questa sera se il livello troppo alto
non dava fare questo e un level sync per
il gioco abbastanza furba perché almeno
un 6 livello 70 e di vai fuori in un
colpo cosa normalmente fattibile se sei
arrivano 60
quindi se prendete il bus come ho fatto
io non è che mi saltate tutte le messe
potete far bere con level sic cosa molto
molto interessante sempre che non mif
accia fuori lo zio è la cosa difficile
ragazzi del mago
la cosa [ __ ] che attacca la distanza
quindi va beh la cosa difficile è che
uno ci mette nel tempo a captare le
stelle e 2 cosa molto molto molto
importante se ti arrivano i nemici in
faccia ti fanno un danno incredibile
cosa che è sempre stata così però
io ho sempre utilizzato i money in tutti
gli import che ho fatto la mia vita
proprio usare questa perché sono bello
assopisca robe del genere infatti sta
dormendo vai vai vai vai vai casta casta
bravo va bene tanto ricordiamoci ragazzi
che io le cose di cura quindi volendo
posso curarmi molteplici volte ragazzi
devo trovare qualcuno per fare il party
scaricatevi il gioco ragazzi facciamo un
party insieme vi prego non solo sta in
questo punto sono da solo salve grazie
ma lei un signore ma lei è fantastico ma
lei mi aiuta ma dio la benedica
salve buongiorno ho visto è vabbè mi
scusi scusi venga qua venga qualche
venga qualche recupero la vita in vite
to party guardi qua come recupero la
vita che lamenta basta guardi restorer è
però deve accettare il partito non restò
rowe niente ma posso farlo lo stesso sa
bene questo è per lei la ringrazio molto
gentile lei e il suo cavallo grosso
sente proprio gentili
grazie signor seal sono tre livelli
avanti a lui solo che io ci ho messo un
secondo lei ecco infatti non faccia
l'arrabbiato comunque lo zio ha dato il
mio nome a un a un office
quindi mi inviteranno nell'agenda
teoricamente vediamo se riusciamo a fare
questo dell'indice orca pacca schifosa a
posto se meno e bastava base uguale
effettivamente con questi livello basso
dovrei andare nelle terre dove c'è il
mio livello più o meno per avere un po
di sfida ma va bene così direi va bene
con level sync almeno per il primo video
prende il re questa non l'avevo visto
scusatemi accettare la prenderei queste
ma certo il signor sir e a hold grida
nia un attimo di pazienza vede se poi i
lati lui si deve chiamare qualcuno in
game alla madonna è più difficile che
registrarsi e al comune va bene comunque
gli posso teletrasportare alla location
al the grid ania che dovrebbe
c'è una specie di bloccando per vederla
boris
non credo che sia a casa sua questa
credo che sia la casa di cosa mi se io
ho cliccato qua ho fatto teletrasporta
non ho capito se avete ascoltato a casa
sua o che cosa
dove mi ha teletrasportato però mamma
mia se non è casa tua la reclamo io
ombre ejarque ombre di zodiac sisma ma
credo che sia a credo che sia la taverna
della gilda ombre di zodiac e ok madonna
ragazzi state messi bene o perfetta la
posso entrare cadetta vernet italiana
ragazzi nessuno
vediamo che la fate la carbonara e un
bel guanciale questa non è musica
italiana prove giorno albe porca vacca
la mamma mia ma certo che accetto ma
possiamo stare in una città migliore di
questo comunque ragazzi vedo che come
gilda è sicuramente impostata per bene
ma torna poi anche accendere spegnere
l'acqua va bene ha figurato e sta cosa
va bene non ho mai giocato ad un po
ordina la mia vita queste cose comunque
andiamo a dormire buona no io ci entrò
in piedi qua dentro prove non so se si è
capito che ci entrò in piedi va bene
complimenti ragazzi per la gilda
comunque ok ragazzi spero non mi mettano
il copyright per sua canzone qua però
vabbè per il resto a tavola rotonda
perfetto stile italiano comunque qua
cieli neri ut va bene signora celina
accettiamola poi non so se innata si
chiama gianmarco nella vita reale
buongiorno volete una mano ragazzi dato
solo qua non mi far fare l'eversivo a no
non posso farli fuori ovviamente se non
sono stancato di livello vera figata
finito per forza farlo leve sync non li
posso toccare è un modo diverso però
figuri vederla roba cosa almeno nessuno
può fare cose esagerate rispetto agli
altri con dipendenti a livello serve
soltanto per sbloccarsi questi potenti e
far fuori i nostri potenti però si figo
ho finito il mana ora cav h a noi fuori
lei giovanile
stavo traghettando un'altra salvezza
quello se n'è fregato proprio gliene
frega niente tranquillo tanto sicuro ios
e schiaffi e cioè in teoria madonna sono
quasi morto io se non subentravo io
secondo me questi qua morivano e ve lo
dico
prego è ci mancherebbe cos'è qua che non
ve faccio cobo keep me né me né dai uno
per cortesia non so libero regali fai la
choco porter grida new minuto 5 gil 5
giri al minuto
ce lo posso cavalcare per cinque giri al
minuto che è un taxi noè tipo l'enjoy sì
ma va da solo va da solo ma basta non lo
voglio ma porca va che volevo comandarlo
non fa sono arrivato dovevo arrivare
comunque cinque giri al minuto non è
neanche una ladrata in realtà ne va bene
salve signor venga qui ma perché se ne
va perché se ne va mi scusi aspetti o
una proposta da farle ai would like to
marry you
dimmi che ci hai un cuore e rispondi
alla mia domanda le ho scritto di
sposarmi alla zia soldi to play off
no è già sposata bye bye enjoy your
husband marito ea sbando brooke logan
thank you
questa gioca incredibile succedono robe
assurde va bene devo socializzare molto
più spesso qui dentro
va bene ho conosciuto un amico mi sono
unità una gilda un sacco di amici ho
fatto comunella con una persona sposata
ho trovato un re e quindi ragazzine che
quest'episodio può concludersi qua però
che vi sia piaciuto
ricordatevi allora volevo creare una
gita ma viene invitato nelle ombre gli
piace abbandonarli perché la nagy la
nostra però magari in futuro lo faremo
nel frattempo connettetevi
iscrivetevi in direct su instagram il
vostro nickname che la prossima volta
che logo dentro
andiamo in giro together in together a
giocare va bene il link lo trovate nella
descrizione ci siamo ragazzi e
possibilità di iscrivere anche l'hai
lasciato un bel mi piace è come sempre
il bellaria
[Musica]